[Applause]
my name is Emily Bashir and Iraqi
comedian and now I'm the host of Iraq's
number one political comedy show
[Applause]
[Music]
people need comedy people need to laugh
about their situation aisel it's the
most dangerous armed group in Iraq right
now our part is to fight them with
comedy we don't have free media in Iraq
news is told with a religious or
political agenda our show is unique
because we criticize every are corrupt
official in the government and also
every armed group when you criticize
powerful people in Iraq of course
there's consequences life in Iraq is
difficult I lost my father I lost my
brother
I lost my cousin and my uncle in Iraq
they are all killed and then I was
kidnapped for six weeks I believe that
we are hoping to improve the situation
in Iraq the show is changing minds
especially among the youth
[Music]
you